a group of Amazon workers walked off the
job in New York City yesterday demanding
their workplace be shut down and cleaned
some employees at Whole Foods which is
owned by Amazon are asking their
co-workers to walk out or call in sick
today a countless number of workers like
these are designated as essential they
show up every day despite their
coronavirus risks to make sure we all
have food and medicine Adriana Diaz
talked with some of them good morning
that's right states like Minnesota
Michigan and Vermont have reclassified
grocery store employees as essential
emergency workers giving them benefits
similar to health care workers and first
responders and some say they feel like
first responders with grocery stores and
pharmacies among the only businesses
open in many states their employees who
come in daily contact with the public
now find themselves unexpectedly on the
frontlines in the back of maryville
pharmacy outside st. Louis brother and
sister pharmacist Kathryn and Harry's
dollars are making their own hand
sanitizer how does it feel different now
than it did just a few days ago it was
like a tension in the air with everyone
and especially in the last week it's
just been slammed based on the panic
while the dollars serve the public at
work they worry about exposing their
loved ones at home their grandmothers of
advanced age we try your best with
precautions when we visit her gloves
mask try to keep 6 feet away which is
very sad because she loves to give hugs
and kisses but there's really nothing we
can do certainly it's stressful but we
got a community to serve what helps you
through this hearing thank you from the
public they thanked us for being there
in a similar way that I've done for
soldiers and firemen there's growing
gratitude at grocery stores to New York
Trader Joe's employee erielle gross
Werder says she appreciates it but knows
it's temporary
right now we are essential workers but
in another two months we'll just be
minimum-wage workers again no one thinks
about we're all being told to stay at
least 6 feet away from one another but
that's really hard to do it
Supermarket yes for sure we're doing
every other register but when somebody
comes with their groceries they usually
from within two feet
she says her parents want her to stop
working but I personally not okay with
the fact that anyone who can afford to
stay home is mend those who cannot
afford to and have to keep going to
their hourly job are the ones at risk
people like single mother Brenda Allen
who's worked for more than 20 years at a
Walmart in Louisiana I know I have to do
my job it's pretty scary but I have no
choice so when you come home what do you
do if anything differently you use Lysol
wipes on your wall Mart has ramped up
hiring and announced employee bonuses
and Trader Joe's has offered additional
paid sick time among other benefits like
so many essential employees the dollars
are determined to keep the virus out so
their doors can stay open we took an
oath as a pharmacist to help any patient
we possibly can and you know we we take
that pretty seriously while we were
interviewing the pharmacists they sold
their last box of masks so they're gonna
have to reuse the masks they were
wearing for as long as they can we also
spoke to a grocery store worker who said
it feels like he's in the infantry right
now he didn't want to go on camera but
he says working at a grocery store these
days
feels like working for the National
Guard or for FEMA that was Adriana Diaz
reporting